der unternehmer muss in eines seiner
büros rund drei kilometer entfernt es
tut mir grad mit carsharing auto in der
nähe damit ich ja mal schnell zu einem
anderen büro fahren kann und bei dem
schönen wetter dachte ich mir so viel
man cabrio raus und hab auch schon 1
gefunden ist nämlich mehr zu und dann
geht's los mit einem chip am
führerschein das auto öffnen
jens scheidemann ist angemeldet bei
einem großen anbieter bei bmw die fahrt
mit dem mini kostet 29 cent pro minute
das angebot gilt bereits in vier
deutschen städten
münchen/düsseldorf bin ich viel
unterwegs und dozierte ausländische noch
carsharing fahrzeuge wo ich früher taxi
gefahren bin
es ist wesentlich günstiger für mich
in deutschland bieten mehr als 100
unternehmen fahrzeuge zum mieten in
berlin ist der wettbewerb am härtesten
viele anbieter locken mit parkplätzen wo
sonst keine zu bekommen sind besonders
schnell aber wächst das mobile
carsharing das kommt ohne feste
stationen aus der kunde darf das auto
stehen lassen wo er will
hier sind die autohersteller groß
eingestiegen daimler sieht sich als
marktführer in der berliner zentrale von
cato melden sie ständig neue
gelegenheitsfahrer an das auto lohnt
sich halt in berlin
bei meiner meinung nach nicht und
deswegen denke ich ist das eine sehr
gute attraktiven das praktisch ist dass
man trinken kann man fährt mit dem car
to go hin und dann wieder
ein taxi zurück ich denke dass es für
meine firma eine gute lösung ist um hier
zweckmäßig und günstig durch die stadt
zu fahren
den autoherstellern allerdings bringt
das geschäft bisher verluste ist
carsharing vielleicht noch eine teure
imagekampagne wir haben es mit
sicherheit nicht gemacht aus
marketinggründen sondern wir wollen
karte wo als eigenes geschäftsmodell
entwickeln wollen sozusagen die
produktpalette von daimler
dadurch erweitern wir gehen davon aus
wie bei jedem neuen unternehmen bis sich
die anfangsinvestitionen orientiert
haben
wenn wir zwei bis drei jahre brauchen
wir fallen also ein zeitraum an 2014
2015 ein stockwerk höher beim
flottenmanager steht das telefon nicht
still
er greift ein wenn was schief läuft
gerade jetzt zum beispiel
polizeiabschnitt 22 hat gerade angerufen
im fahrzeug blockierte einfahrt und
steht auch offenbar hat der kunde ist
nicht wirklich richtig abgemeldet und
fahrzeug wurde umgesetzt und der
schlüssel wurde jetzt sichergestellt die
häufigsten einsätze für das serviceteam
putzen und tanker täglich müssen rund
100 autos gewartet werden zehn prozent
der berliner flotte der aufwand lohne
sich sagt der branchenverband die
dienstleistung sei ein zukunftsgeschäft
die deutschen hersteller beginnen in der
heimat hier in deutschland
dort wird sich das angebot noch
ausweiten aber es wird nicht auf
deutschland begrenzt bleiben wir werden
auch den europäischen markt in angriff
nehmen und auch den beispielsweise den
us amerikanischen markt auch da werden
wir die modernsten carsharing angebote
der deutschen hersteller sehen
der arbeitstag ist zu ende unternehmer
scheidemann holt sein sohn von der
schule ab der ist das längst gewöhnt
dass sein vater öfter mal mit einem
anderen auto kommt